the trouble with Crimea starts with
getting there at its narrowest point the
two-mile body of water separates it from
Russia roads which go through Ukraine
are all but closed flames aside the only
way to get from the Russian mainland to
the Crimean Peninsula over here is to
take this boat across the Kerr Strait
that is until Russia builds a bridge
it's planning on the span the distance
these Russians are entering what is
legally speaking Ukraine no need for a
passport though as far as they're
concerned this is a domestic crossing
ever since Russia annexed this area
crimeans have been somewhat stuck new
passport can take weeks
the old ones aren't very helpful the
Ukrainians aren't allowing men between
the ages of 18 and 60 into Ukraine even
with Ukrainian passports they call us
terrorists Ukrainian and foreign banks
have all closed while many of Russia's
have yet to open most cash machines and
credit cards don't work
even in the cradle of Russian orthodoxy
prices are quoted first in Ukrainian
money losin Russian rubles in small
print doing business in a contested
region isn't easy and potentially
illegal golden arches and much more
stand deserted tourists also face
obstacles to visit the place where the
Allies met in 1945 world war ii buffs
must now travel to Russia this is the
very room of the Yalta Conference took
place a couple months ago Americans like
me could have come here without a visa
now that it's ended Moscow's control not
anymore
there wasn't any unrest while we were in
Crimea but Russia is clearly concerned
there could be gathering of the region's
Muslim minority was banned
Russia's new his tourist destination is
breathtaking just beneath the surface
there are problems cranes cut the water
supply and further inland
they're expecting droughts but most
Crimean say even with all the trouble
it's a price worth paying